chaque fois c'est la même histoire elle
est joyeuse quand arrive est bouleversée
contre repart c'est très dur pour elle
tu sais mon coeur je vais travailler
[Musique]
s'est bien passé des lituaniens ouais ça
va ton fils a appelé je veux dire notre
fils ah non quand il m'énerve c'est que
le tien
[Musique]
vous embrasse je vous ai dit tu sais
c'est qu'on travaille fait au téléphone
tu as dit je vous embrasse rajouter quoi
tu joues tu m'excuses
qu'est ce que vous faites là bas j'avais
la même question chère margot je savais
pas que vous connaissez sur la belgique
[Musique]
ça vous faire des choses comme ça
saucier de préparer
comme ça tu vois un permanente à tout le
monde tu me fais peur
[Musique]
il faut pas piller cet excitant une
femme comme toi tu viens ici il fait ça
ne pas être effrayé alors que les
défrayer
du maroc gagne
[Musique]
mais toi qui m'a coupé du monde toi tais
toi et moi j'invente m
[Musique]
à
quel est votre nom au mad
question 5